intel s'est félicitée mme on veut on
veut pas des comédiens tableau vous me
lisez ça à comines tél
merci mme à la salle est si forte si tu
aimes les grosse [ __ ] retrouve sur
36 15 que quito tu verras je tenais plus
debout que de charras les deux de gros
mots que chara ce génie sur mon cheveu
et en plus j'avais là goulasch alors
rejoint vite je vais te dresser moi je
suis pour le premier sage rim on veut
pas de comédien pour les gens de la rue
dans un marché vous regarder la caméra
et vous lisez le texte simplement
envoyer toute l'équipe à l'effort pour
les soirs d'accord d'accord
si tu aimes et mal les vrais rejoint
moins vite sur 36 15 codes homo aller
pour bardy 2 bis rue king et busy
entente alors à tout de suite mon gros
phoque jean président avance regarder la
caméra est dit un tout petit mon gros
faute à 38 bon gros phoque situer mais
grosse [ __ ] retrouve mois sur 36 15
colt python pistes pour que alors
rejoins moi vite je vais te dresser mois
donc petite avance alors vous faites
état de fait simple
second jean frétille d'avancé et vous
dites parce que moi j'en ai une deux et
vous montrer le panneau allez-y parce
que moi j'en ai une 2 2 puis pour la
messagerie homosexuels avec votre visage
par un gros merci mon bac je vais te
dresser mois insultes
kikou plaqueur joe va te faire [ __ ]
[ __ ] nom vient de la foot wallon vient
de faire [ __ ] bien me prendre
on va faire plein de trucs sympas c'est
bon c'est sûr que la france s'y met pas
en garde fous à moi j'ai rien contre les
pdf on a fait
c'est celle perdue pour vous les pays
elle faisait dire enfin tout faire des
conneries après vous engueuler sur les
conneries tu parles il a trouvé quand
vous êtes trouvé un boulot là vous allez
faire [ __ ] à plein temps merci là
vous allez toucher plein de mecs des
copains à moi je les sentais chez pas
mal je crois que vous avez pas chômé au
niveau 2 de tout quoi merci abengourou
ma ville mais ça m'est égal à mon agent
russe carrière acgp une bise et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu